so
[Music]
our drone pictures show the sandy scar
that once was the manibova river in
southern madagascar families are trying
to find water they've been reduced to
digging holes in order to reach the
water table and the riverbed is pitted
with what they've gouged out
they do their laundry in whatever liquid
they can find they wash themselves in
this and they drink this they have no
choice
this is what the worst drought in forty
years has meant for people here
it is as stark an image as you will get
of just how changing weather patterns
are impacting this terribly poor country
and how so many people here are
suffering
this is an example of what's happening
to this country the fourth
largest island in the world now so prone
to extremes of weather that it's having
a massive impact on the survival of of
the country with the united nations
describing them as the
first country which is on the brink of
famine as a result of climate change
so the main health center at amber wambi
is crowded with hungry babies and
mothers many of them are in obvious
discomfort with bulging stomachs and
yellowing hair the telltale signs of
acute malnutrition some have walked up
to 15 kilometers to get here but here
they'll be given aid and that just might
save them
franco has called forward the 10 month
old has been worrying the health workers
last week she'd lost a whole kilo weight
she simply cannot afford to shed
but her cries are a good sign it means
she has the strength to protest and this
week there's a small cause for
celebration she's gained a few grams
for the first time her anxious mother
smiles
i'm very happy she tells us
but as the nurses measure her arms the
tape still shows she's in the red zone
well below what she should be measuring
and not out of danger
everyone here is hungry the world bank
estimates more than 90 of the malagasy
live on less than two dollars a day
these are the ones who've made it to an
aid center even so this desperation
causes enormous stress
most here will go to bed hungry tonight
most don't know where their next meal is
coming from
most parents will not be able to feed
all their children and some won't be
able to feed any of them
the lack of water has had a huge
knock-on effect not least on health with
poor sanitation increasing and ramping
up disease
revo has worked in the south for nearly
two decades and seen the droughts become
longer and more extreme each year
in all my years the worst was last year
and it's set to get even worse this year
the extreme weathers hit the most
vulnerable and those least able to
withstand
it climate change is killing and
malalaza is one of madagascar's younger
victims
she's barely got the strength to turn
her head
she's the weight of a typical newborn
she's actually a year and two months old
with few reserves to fight disease
she's now got tuberculosis that is too
weak to make anything other than tiny
murmurs of pain
she's living and slowly dying and the
warnings about what the un calls an
impending climate change famine aren't
new there's been years leading to this
yet the health workers have few weapons
to fight this environmental war and
without a shot being fired they're
seeing suffering on a huge scale
and they are losing with the bulk of the
country so poor they're struggling to
get enough to eat
malalaza's mother says she's battling to
feed any of her six children
and walks 10 kilometers to find water
seeing how tough her life is carrying
water lots of physical activity
this could be what's led to the baby's
state
there are other contributory factors
decades of poor governance are blamed
and the covert pandemic has hit the
economy shutting down the tourism which
provided hard currency
there's very little infrastructure and
we traveled on mostly unpaved roads
many communities are extremely remote so
what aid there is is difficult to
deliver
but the increasingly extreme weather has
made subsistence farming even tougher
many are being driven to sell or eat the
herds they rely on and people are
becoming more and more desperate
these young herdsmen didn't want to be
interviewed
but picking up rocks and waving their
farming tools they demand money to let
us through
and then sit down in front of our
vehicles and refuse to budge until we do
our malagasy colleagues begin
negotiations as the herdsmen tell them
they're hungry and they need money for
food our drivers reluctantly hand over
cash
when we reach the nearest village of
marofu the village elder in orange is
appalled at the attempted hold up raids
on the meager crops here are on the rise
he's anxious to show us how malnourished
the children are and many are showing
signs of acute malnutrition
this is all they now have to eat cactus
flowers which are devoured very quickly
they offer some relief from hunger pangs
but they will bloat their bellies and
cause cramps later
many have blistered lips and the wizard
skin of those three times their age
of course these are not enough for us
but we've no choice hariba tells us
no one has electricity here only 15
percent of the whole country does
so many live in medieval conditions
rouhani sua has two wives and two large
families for the total of 16 children to
feed the population is soaring by nearly
three percent a year but in a country
more than twice the size of britain it
still has fewer than half the number of
citizens
[Music]
i can't ever fill these bowls with
enough food for them he says and we're
always hungry but i watered the rice
down to make it go further
the village elder insists on escorting
us out his instincts are correct the
herdsmen have been waiting for us to
leave on the single track out the young
men are scolded as they protest they
need help
everyone is hungry
we traveled on to the most southern tip
of the country
the shifting sand of faux cap is never
dormant and blankets everything
it's threatening livelihoods and burying
homes and buildings this was the police
station
and this the local government office now
so covered were able to stand on its
roof
the phenomenon known here as teomina or
red storm has been dramatically changing
this indian ocean coastline ravaging
crops and stifling development
the people in the south have not only
been hit by the long drought but also
fierce winds which often halts the
fishing which is one of the main sources
of income
henry claude the head of the village
hasn't been out on the water for more
than a week now
some of the brave or the desperate opt
for other methods but it can be
dangerous and often fruitless
honoree claude shows us the rows of
sizal trees the village has planted to
try to restore this degraded land and
rescue the ecosystem
it's a long-term strategy with the
greenest of weapons
many of them are just plain scared not
just of the future but the here and now
we're afraid of living here he says and
many people are leaving
they're afraid of the invasion by the
dunes and we just can't get investment
here
the violent winds blow off roofs and
make a living that's already hard even
harder
and there are signs many of the
villagers have already abandoned their
homes and been forced to move on
so they're turning to other ways to
survive
and by the look of this market
madagascar's forests are being plundered
and sold at an alarming rate
but all this has added to large-scale
deforestation with madagascar losing 40
of its forest since the 1950s
we don't have anything to eat we don't
have anything to drink we cut the wood
because of the care he says
what the malagasy called the drought
that brings hunger
and right now madagascar is burning away
its future to get through the present
racking up one of the highest rates of
deforestation in any tropical country
that's put its ecosystem at risk
destroying its habitat and putting the
vast range of unique wildlife it's home
to in great danger
we spotted an extremely rare radiated
tortoise out in the open and lifted it
away from the road it's critically
endangered and only found here in the
south of madagascar but it's being
killed for its meat or captured by
poachers at such a rate that
conservationists warn it could disappear
from the wild forever within 20 years
these creatures are now very much at
risk because the situation is so
critical in madagascar that they fetch a
huge price on the black market and if
any of these are smuggled to order
usually out to the far eastern markets
they can raise thousands and thousands
of dollars
but if caught
you face a very stiff prison sentence
the island contributes only 0.001 per
cent of global carbon emissions yet it's
feeling the most impact of climate
change
we trekked into the forest on the
eastern coast and within minutes saw
wildlife found nowhere else on the
planet
the country is widely considered to be
the most biodiverse on earth
if the country's put in peril its
citizens and its environmental heritage
are too
this is a protected forest
but there are so many more areas of
madagascar which are
being destroyed
it's incredible to think that there are
hundreds and hundreds of species here in
madagascar that you will not find
anywhere else
in the world
and many conservationists believe that
they are now in danger
sinji's been traveling through this
forest for two decades he's never seen
it so bad
it's not good the chain the trend coming
hot high
hot
and dry
right
and
the rain coming
if they come
rain too much no stop
and flood everywhere
the malagasy government has so many
tough challenges and weaning its
population of its dependence on coal is
just one of them they want the richer
countries to help them and other african
nations fund greener fuel alternatives
but right now the malagasy people are
just fighting to live every day and they
desperately want change
[Music]
you